profession nous travaillons à distance
et donc les formes traditionnelles de
diplomatie et les presses c'est à dire
les conférences de presse les rencontres
aujourd'hui tout cela est pour le moment
suspendu et puisque la question se pose
de savoir qu'elle est dans ces
conditions l'activité diplomatique de la
russie donc je vais mener cette
conférence de presse et répondent à vos
questions je suis prêt et dennis va
diriger cette activité chers collègues
on va commencer à va commencer par un
milliard kukushkin
bonjour monsieur lavrov est ce que vous
envisagez la possibilité de changer les
règles de sortie des russes à l'étranger
après le coronavirus après l'ouverture
des frontières et quels changements
peuvent être faits par exemple les visas
ou les tests obligatoires test de
dépistage pour l'instant cette question
n'a été traitée par personne et je crois
que il ya beaucoup de gens dans notre
pays qui souhaitent partir à l'étranger
en principe il n'y a pas d'interdiction
particulière puisque le droit de
circulation fait partie de notre
constitution
simplement il s'agit pour l'heure de
faire en sorte que le moins de personnes
possibles soit on dément ce tomb malade
et donc nous travaillons de façon tout à
fait opérationnel et nous nous en tenons
strictement à cette règle encore une
fois le droit de partir du pays
personne n'a l'intention de mettre en
place des dispositions particulières
mais je je ne je ne prendrais pas le
risque de dire que des changements vont
avoir lieu dans la constitution pour
entrer ou sortir du pays maintenant
maria finances hina rt rachat ajouté ah
bonjour à tous mais sur lavrov chers
collègues je suis ravi de vous voir même
dans ce format en ligne ma question est
si liées au gros navires us washington
continue de critiquer les actions de
l'organisation mondiale de santé
comment la russie évalue ce comportement
dans la situation où le monde entier
tous les pays presque tous les pays
luttent ensemble avec le ms contre le
coronavirus dans cette situation de
pandémie
est ce que ces critiques sont elles
utiles pratiques et constructive ou non
merci merci oui en principe ce café
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
toutes les mesures qu'elle a prises sont
connus n'importe qui peut prendre
connaissance de la chronologie et des
mesures qui ont été prises à ce temps
par cette organisation c'est que cette
organisation a travaillé de façon
efficace et c'est un fait que l' oms
continue de jouer un rôle majeur dans la
lutte contre la pandémie et en même
temps lors de la décision récente du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu aussi dans
le cadre du g20 qui étaient réunis à
distance récemment tout le monde a
soutenu ce consensus ce consensus de
l'om et c est moi je me m'abstiendrai de
politiser cette union l'a7
c'est pas seulement à propos du navire
us même si à propos aussi d'accusation
qui ont été formulés de la part de
certains pays
aujourd'hui il ya des mesures concrètes
pour freiner cette pandémie pour limiter
sa propagation
pour certains cherchent à minimiser ses
efforts dans la protection de la santé
de la population
donc ces campagnes qui ont été lancés et
les erreurs de cette campagne
encore une fois ensuit concerne l' oms
nous en avons parlé nous parlons de la
façon de talent âgé et n'oublions pas
que cette organisation est que les états
unis sont un des principaux
contributeurs de cette organisation et
que donc ils ont toujours forcément une
influence sur ces structures l'om s
la majorité ce sont des américains qui
sont poste directeur qui sont des
spécialistes est qui qui prennent des
décisions en toute conscience
merci à nos partenaires étrangers
dominent la chaîne chinoise
bonjour monsieur lavrov à nous avons
aussi noté que la propagation du
coronavirus a changé la vie
internationale économique politique elle
selon vous quels mécanismes faut-il
créer actuellement pour que les pays
clés du monde appuie sur le thé ensemble
contre cette pandémie et est-ce qu'il
s'agit d'une menace à la paix la
sécurité dans le monde entier
si on ne gagne rapidement
vous savez bien sûr la pandémie se crée
un certain nombre de problèmes et
principalement en ce qui concerne les
mets directement notre préoccupation
c'est de sauver la vie des gens que les
gens se trouvent dans en sécurité en
sécurité sur le plan des médicaments de
la santé etc
et évidemment le lieu d'habitation
l'environnement dans lequel vit
l'humanité tout cela et c'est important
le deuxième défi qui se pose est faut
être paresseux papa le l'évoqué c'est la
situation économique dans le pays dans
le monde
et puisque cette épidémie influence tous
les échanges commerciaux les cours des
valeurs
vous voyez ce qui se passe avec eux
ce qui se passe autour de la l'offre et
de la demande sur certains produits
essentiels et en particulier les
produits énergétiques
donc ici certains pays certaines
organisations dans l'équipe dont font
partie ces pays on voit ici que ici et
des applications qui sont importantes
mais le troisième défi c'est la
situation qui se pose aujourd'hui par
une panne notamment sur la question de
la stabilité des états et des
organisations qui les comprennent mais
ici
cette menace générale cette menace
mondiale peut être surmontée et il va
falloir réfléchir revoir peut-être
beaucoup de choses dans l'activité
d'organisations internationales comment
elle fonctionne aujourd'hui par exemple
on voit aujourd'hui c'est que pensent
les européens de l'union européenne de
l'otan et cetera des échanges de ces
questions se posent aussi sur le
territoire de l'ancienne urss
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai tout cela donc il va y avoir
des discussions importantes
ça concerne le g20 le brix toussaint je
vous rappelle que en 2019
dans le cadre du brics il avait été mis
en place une coopération au niveau de
l'élaboration de vaccin est donc
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est une grande
actualité et si on parle des relations
russie chine
face à cette pandémie dès le début de la
crise nous avons commencé à coopérer dès
le début et début février par exemple de
cette année nous avons évacué nos
citoyens de houra nous nous avons laissé
une
aide humanitaire aujourd'hui nous avons
aussi une aide de la part de nos amis
chinois qui ont réussi à surmonter a
passé le pic de l'épidémie et qui
retrouve une vie normale donc
aujourd'hui nous nous tenons et nous
devons continuer à nous tenir à ce
principe essentiel de la coopération
interfax bonjour messieurs la robe l'
agence interfax margherita velkova nous
voudrions savoir est-ce que selon vous
la situation avec le coronavirus peut
avoir un impact sur l'organisation du
sommet septembre à new york un sommet
des pays membres permanents du conseil
de sécurité et est ce que ce serait peut
être organisé plus tôt pour trouver la
réponse à cette crise est une autre
question est ce que vous envisagez la
possibilité d'organiser cette réunion en
ligne
je dirai tout de suite ce qu' il n'y a
aucun accord qui a été conclu sur le
sommet ce que je peux dire que tous nos
partenaires du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu et nous avons dit que ceux de ce
sommet sera solide physiquement il vait
unien les pays
les dirigeants des pays du conseil de
sécurité il ya un accord sur le fait que
l'orientation de cette rencontre sera
importante ce sera une analyse de tout
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans le
monde dans tous les domaines liés à la
sécurité à la vie des gens en matière de
sécurité de ceux de stabilité de de paix
et nous travaillons au niveau des
ministères des affaires étrangères et je
sais que des délais avait été indiqué
peut-être pour septembre
aujourd'hui on en parle mais
on est en contact au niveau des
différents dirigeants en ce qui concerne
les possibilités d'une visioconférence
nous l'excusons l'excluons pas mais cela
ne rend sera pas ne remplacera pas une
rencontre directe
simplement aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ça
nous permet de travailler les uns avec
les autres pour voir quelles sont les
mesures à prendre
aujourd'hui dès maintenant pour lutter
contre cette dans cette crise merci mais
cela vaut bonjour je voudrais demander
si admis la ministre des affaires
étrangères du conseil de l'europe sera
organisé mais parce que votre homologue
grec au hamas a dit récemment qu'il
voulait vous rencontrer le plus vite
possible
il était même prêt à porter la masse qu
est ce que c'est possible d'organiser ce
sommet en mai est notre question après
l'épidémie est ce que c'est diplomatie
en ligne restera très pratique
ensuite concernant chrome os dans la
mesure où il l'a dit publiquement
moi j'ai rien et moi et m'a rien dit en
direct mais je veux le dire le
transmettre de la même façon mon
invitation qu'il vienne à tout moment
s'il a le moyen de venir à moscou dès
qu'ils arrivent ici de la sécurité
totale selon lui sera assuré qu'ils
viennent et qu'on m'écoute et je le dis
tout à fait sérieusement en ce qui
concerne le conseil des ministres de
l'union européenne et qui devait se
tenir au mois de mai pour achever la
présidence géorgienne
les géorgiens eux mêmes avaient demandé
que ça se tiennent à strasbourg en
raison de leurs problèmes internes que
je ne vais pas commenter mais en raison
du corona virus la décision était faite
a été prise
2le l'organiser en novembre en grèce
puisque la grèce va prendre la
succession de la géorgie à la présidence
de ce conseil
en ce qui concerne l'activité
diplomatique si elle se déplace en dans
le mode de visio conférence cette
méthode je pense qu'elle sera
effectivement utilisé est là elle était
déjà utilisé avant même l'apparition de
cette bande d'amis mais cela ne
remplacera jamais les rencontres
personnel y est des choses qui par
définition ne peuvent être discutés que
entre quatre yeux et ça je l' ai déjà
dit tous ces moyens modernes de pointe
technologies ils ne pourront jamais
remplacer la relation personnelle
d'autant plus qu' il ya des choses qui
ne peuvent pas être confiée au papier ni
aux moyens électroniques de
communication mais qui ne peuvent être
discutés que dans des conditions de
confidentialité et de confiance indique
la russie pour l'espace la russie attend
que cherchant à obtenir
c'est simplement que c'est la suite de
notre dialogue avec les états unis qui
date depuis très longtemps c'est à dire
quels sont les mécanismes les problèmes
qui nous paraissent pour moscou pour
washington qui nous paraissent
d'actualité aujourd'hui
donc il ya beaucoup de questions de
coopération entre nos deux pays et qui
peuvent être utiles et bien entendu tout
ce qui concerne l'espace
c'est un de ces problèmes tous nos pays
occupe une position majeure les
discussions entre par exemple la
communication entre le président poutine
et l'équipage sur la station
internationale et avec le président
américain qui s'est déroulée justement
le jour 2 de l'espace le 12 avril donc
nous avons des discussions qui sont
encore plus concrète ligne en matière de
coopération sur la stabilité
internationale il ya quelques semaines
j'ai reçu un appel de mike p o et
j'espère parlé avec lui encore
prochainement ces jours-ci s'agit
notamment des discussions sur le
contrôle des armements la stabilité
stratégique et nous allons évidemment
tout intérêt de la part de nos
partenaires américains sur des sujets
qui sont et qui méritent évidemment une
grande attention nos adjoints et
participent à ces discussions mais nous
voudrions avoir des discussions encore
plus concrètes notamment sur le le
traité sur les armes offensives et donc
d'autres notamment en matière aussi de
discussion sur les nouveaux armements
armements et personnic et caetera et
nous devons traiter tous les aspects
sans exception tous les aspects qui
influent sur la situation de stratégique
il ya aussi la question de la
militarisation de l'espace et
il y a aussi la question de
l'utilisation d'armes conventionnelles
d'essais nucléaires il ya beaucoup de
sujets de discussion et nous voudrions
tout c'est discuter de toutes ces
questions et en particulier de l'espace
à propos de l'espace nous sommes tout à
fait prêts à discuter avec nos collègues
américains notamment avec à propos de
notre initiative russo chinoises de
refus de militarisation
mais les américains ne veulent pas
donner le feu vert à cette initiative
donc nous sommes prêts à discuter cette
discussion pour une utilisation
pacifique des les moyens technologiques
utilisés dans l'espace il ya un
mémorandum qui avait été signé par le
président train concernant la conquête
de l'espace et l'a souligné que les
états unis traitent cette question sur
la base des principes énoncés dans le
traité sur l'espace et autres corps
interstellaire et la russie participants
de ces discussions et et comme et comme
les américains nous ne sommes pas
participants d'autres désaccords
notamment sur la lune aucune des
puissances spatiales n'est participants
tenaient signataires de ce document
mais il ya le texte de 1966 et je pense
que à la lumière des initiatives qui ont
été proposées par le président trump
notamment dans ce mémorandum est il y
ait nécessité de bénéficier d'un soutien
international à ce plan
2 conquête de l'espace nous nous
considérons que cette approche est juste
de façon à trouver un compromis sur ces
questions les autorités de pag on
détruit le monument au marshall connaît
ve qui a participé à la libération de
cette ville et la russie a proposé de ne
pas le détruire et de l'exporter en
russie mais la prague a refusé bien
entendu les actions de cet essai pas les
têtes de prague sont particulièrement
troublante nous sommes indignés et elles
vont en contradiction avec l'accord qui
a été signé avec la république tchèque
et d'autres en vigueur en 1993 il
comprend le l'obligation d'entretenir
les monuments historiques assurer la
sécurité et l'accès à ces monuments
et quand les tchèques disent qu'ils
n'ont pas à entraver l'exécution de cet
accord
évidemment il joue avec les mots ce qui
s'est passé j'ai attiré l'attention sur
la déclaration du président tchèque
milos zeman il a dit lui même que cette
décision concernant le monument était
stupide
ceux-ci sape les accords qui sont à la
base de nos relations de peu de nos
relations depuis presque trente ans
néanmoins c'est un fait et on nous
assure que ce monument appartenant à la
municipalité de prague
mais nous savons bien que ce n'est pas
le cas puisque avant son démontage
il faisait partie de
la liste du registre des monuments qui
devaient être gérés en vertu de l'accord
de 1993 nous ne sommes pas indifférents
on voit que en république tchèque un
certain nombre de responsables d'acteurs
de la vie sociale sont indignés
voir cette décision je sais qu'il ya une
action en justice qui a été intentée sur
place à prague 6 est donc un certain
nombre d'organisations non
gouvernementales sont mécontentes de
cette décision et exprimé leur
solidarité à l'égard de la russie dans
cette contestation des résultats de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
un petit détail est intéressant c'est
que la décision a été prise par la
municipalité de prague
6 divisez dirigée par monsieur courage
et le père de monsieur collage à son
étai avait fait partie du ministère des
affaires étrangères tchèque il avait été
en poste aux états unis et en russie et
il travaille avec une société de conseil
américaine qui a proposé pour les
responsables municipaux chèques qu'ils
avaient préparés justement un rapport
sur la façon de démonter ces moments
mais nous allons lutter pour que le
traité de 1993 soit respectée
correctement et
notamment pour éviter une aggravation de
sa c2 cette situation tandis que appelle
des livraisons russes vous savez comme
le grand scientifique ce métier que par
l'ofs avait découvert les réflexes là on
voit les mêmes réflexe de pavlov phobie
qu'il s'agisse de la pandémie
l'entrée dans cette pandémie et après
quand elle disparaîtra je pense ses
réflexes se continueront à exister
il ya des gens qui ceux qui ne vivent
que ces deux sets ce faux billets ils
n'arrivent pas à s'adapter autrement la
russophobie comme le montre la pratique
peut vivre très bien elle peut
bénéficier du soutien de certains pays
et je pense que cela est très
regrettable mais j'ai déjà répondu à
propose des questions qui ont été posées
il faut voir le rôle de certains états
dans la manifestation de certains défis
dans le monde et la question se pose de
la viabilité de certaines structures
internationales de discussion certaines
unions qui s' agit seul euro atlantique
en eurasie où dans d'autres zones et
nous aurons besoin de savoir si nous
voulons faire de la morale ou est ce que
c'est une bd hd
tâche qui va nous incombe donc si on as
des conceptions qui vont chercher ceux
qui étaient en commun pour le mann heat
et les chinois l'ont fait ils ont été
critiqués pour les bonnes paroles qui
derrière lesquelles se cacherait certain
intérêt peut-être mais en tout cas les
chinois ont proposé qu'on discute tous
ensemble et ça consiste à unir nos
efforts
or aujourd'hui on voit des efforts qui
cherche uniquement à contenir la russie
lui aussi donc c'est une autre
philosophie c'est une philosophie qui
est négative qui part d'un principe
négatif
là il s'agit de forme de confrontation
dans le monde et je pense que ceux qui
[Musique]
cherchent à faire carrière dans ce
domaine
après l'épidémie de corona virus je
pense qu'ils vont être quand même moins
nombreux et de moins en moins christina
votre microphone n'est pas activé
d'accord on va faire une petite pause on
va donner la parole à itar tass
vladimir quoi ses rêves bonjour monsieur
lavrov et à dix jours la russie a envoyé
aux états unis un avion chargés d'aidé
de matériel pour le thé contre le cros
navires us qu est ce que nous
envisageons d'envoyer des d'un
partenaire américain et compte tenu de
ce que vous avez dit sur l'intention de
développer le dialogue avec les états
unis dans le domaine de l'espace et les
armements pour ça les contacts sont
nécessaires est ce que maintenant au
niveau de vous dix ministres ya dessus
des contacts avec les américains
l'équipement médical et les consommables
qui ont été envoyés aux états unis et
sur la base d'un accord direct entre les
deux présidents russe et américain
les américains étaient intéressés à
recevoir
vous savez que le chargement qui est
envoyé à été payée en vertu des
des règles d'affaires si une demande
supplémentaire de la part des américains
est envoyé pour des matériels de ce type
lame nous l'examinerons bien évidemment
et au cours de leur dernier entretien
avant-hier les présidents poutine d'être
up et le président de trappes a encore
répété que si la russie et besoins
supplémentaires
et quand la production américaine sera
bien réglé à ce moment là des livraisons
pourront se faire et cela me paraître
normal entre partenaires en ce qui
concerne les discussions comme je les ai
déjà dit aujourd'hui nous travaillons
tous en mode à distance et sur les
thèmes que vous avez qui ont été évoqués
en matière de stabilité
on peut parler en toute sérénité sous
forme de visioconférence et par
téléphone mais est bien évidemment il ya
des sujets qui vaut mieux ne pas
remettre à plus tard et qui nécessitent
des discussions directes
parmi les sanctions américaines et
européennes doivent être levés le plus
tôt possible et comment cela peut être
lié à la pandémie du courant d'un virus
on dirait que ça peut te lieu
mais ce que le secrétaire général de
l'onu antonio guterres achats déjà dit
ainsi que michelle bachelet responsables
les droits de l'homme au sein de l'onu
donc c'est une mobilisation de tous les
efforts ici contre le coronavirus et
parmi ces mesures c'est ils ont dit
qu'il fallait renoncer aux sanctions
unilatérales qui met un frein à la
livraison de aux fournitures de matériel
médical et des d'humanitaires et qu'il
s'agit ici de suivre les recommandations
des médecins
les sanctions ne sont pas légitimes en
elle même et quand elle met un frein à
la lutte contre la pandémie
et quand elles sont prises en plus à en
contournant les décisions de l'onu à ce
moment là ils sont en tout elles sont
complètement illégal ray par exemple
l'entrepreneur chinois jack ma qui a
envoyé une aide médicale pour l'amérique
latine
c'était considéré comme une aide mais ce
qu'a fait cuba n'a pas été acceptée donc
ici c'est à dire que les américains
interdisent en utilisant leur position
sur le marché de ses produits
ils utilisent des comptes en dollars
pour les échanges commerciaux bien à mon
grand regret c'est indigne de la part
des américains
ils ont lancé une campagne d décribilise
ation des médecins cubains qui ont
apporté une aide dans plusieurs pays
alors et qui travaillent de façon
efficace en amérique latine
et dans d'autres régions et déjà avant
la pandémie donc ils ont fait preuve la
grande qualité nationale ici il apporte
une aide aujourd'hui dans une
soixantaine de pays et je crois que
c'est très appréciable cet effort de la
part des cubains mais je répète encore
une fois il est important que le
caractère immoral de ces sanctions
unilatérales qui affecte les relations
humanitaire il faut que cela soit fasse
l'objet d'un accord international et
l'assemblée générale de l'onu avait
adopté un texte sur la lutte contre le
corona virus et je pense qu'on aura
d'autres résolutions qui sont prises et
qui sont diffusés comme documents
officiels et aussi les déclarations des
70 qui ont été émises et qui disent
clairement que les sanctions
unilatérales ne peuvent être admises en
aucun cas surtout quand on est dans un
contexte où il ya une menace pour toute
l'humanité et nous discutons avec au
niveau du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
en lien avec l'accord nager sous
traitant de ces questions
je pense que le dans toutes ses
décisions le conseil de sécurité doit
envisager cette question que les
sanctions unilatérales ne peuvent être
tolérés
quelle que soit la situation et
d'évolution que nous allons connaître la
russie s'en tiennent au jour sans la
russie s'en tiennent en tout on s'en
tient en tout cas à ce principe d' aide
d'humanitaire général
et quand des discussions ont lieu au
sein du conseil de sécurité
quand des sanctions on nous dit en
général que les sanctions se sont pas
contre des personnes mais ce sont contre
contre des régimes pour que les régimes
champions c'est pas vrai c'est pas du
tout
regardez le résultat des actions contre
le venezuela contre l'iran contre le
tuba contre la syrie c'est une un
dommage directs causés aux populations
et donc c'est c'est sanctions ne doivent
pas toucher le caractère humanitaire
elles ne font qu'aggraver la situation
humanitaire dans ces situations nous
voudrions savoir ce que pensent et sur
les pétitions forces progressistes
italie en france et des efforts d'autres
coupes visant à lever le blocus de cuba
de la part des états unis parce que
c'est une politique cynique dans la
situation où le monde entier lute contre
vous savez répond ont répondu et la
réponse est dans la question la
politique de sanctions étaient là pour
l'exciter politique de blocus de cuba et
que les etats-unis mènent depuis
plusieurs décennies
elle n'est soutenue quasiment par
personne et chaque année l'assemblée
générale de l'onu adopte une résolution
contre ce blocus en le demandant de me
mettre fin et la dernière qui a été
adoptée en décembre de l'an dernier avec
un record maximum de voix avec plus de
187 contre 3 donc avec les etats-unis le
brésil malheureusement est encore
quelqu'un d'autre et deux pays et
s'étaient abstenus donc notamment
l'ukraine ce qui est regrettable mais là
la majorité écrasante ont demandé de
mettre fin à cette pratique honteuse et
malheureusement ces signaux restent
malheureusement sans sans résultats de
la part des américains mais c'est
complètement anti contre productif
cuba a de bonnes relations avec rire
tous les pays et nous sommes convaincus
que nos amis communs aux cubains sont
tout à fait prêts avoir de bonnes
relations avec les états unis
donc sur la base d'un respect mutuel et
du célé et de la charte de l'onu
des principes directeurs de l'onu et les
cubains doivent pouvoir décider de leur
ca destin à vous la parole
non ça ne marche pas christina ça ne
marche pas désolé pour le moment
malheureusement on ne nous en a pas
galeno polanska yayoro news merci
messieurs lavrov bonjour vous avez
appelé à ne pas politiser la situation
avec l'épidémie du courant d'un virus
mais on voit cette politisation et la
russie est aussi elle est accusée de la
politisation le ministre européen des
affaires étrangers a accusé la russie de
livrer de l'aide par exemple en italie
pour renforcer son veau la géopolitique
dans le monde et comment la situation et
la politique étrangère de russie changé
dans les conditions du recours aux
navires us et comment la politique
mondiale peut être changer après cette
pandémie merci ensuite ça notre première
question il ya plusieurs proverbe
pour comprendre que chacun mesure tout à
sa propre zone chacun sa propre
éducation ce concerne les questions
strictement humanitaires et les
confrontations monde
c'est dommage que tout cela ait provoqué
ce que vous avez cité certains je
cherche à faire de mouches un éléphant
mais tout ceci ce qui se passe en italie
par exemple ça a été présentée quasiment
comme une intervention armée dans un
pays de l'otan
malheureusement on a vu ça dans certains
médias en italie tout à fait récemment
par exemple dans la stampa
il ya eu un article sur ce sujet qui
proclamait qui cherchait à à discréditer
l'aide apportée à la chine mais il ya
des choses très simple c'est que ceux
qui m'aiment je suis un port elle par
exemple affirmé des sources
c'est une demande directe du premier
ministre monsieur duceppe escomptés il
s'est adressé à la russie et notre
ambassade à rome reçoit des dizaines 1
d'appels de messages de reconnaissance
de la part des italiens ordinaire et
enfin 7 à ces tentatives de minimiser
l'aide ou de la d'enfer lui donner un
caractère géopolitique
vous avez dit que la chine avance aussi
de tels jeux sous ça dommage parce que
les chinois justement bien
surmonter sceptre le pic de cette année
mais il se referme pas sur eux au
contraire il faisait des recherches
aider les autres pays
quand on voit des discussions sur le
fait que la chine devra payer des
indemnités à tout le monde pour avoir
été à la source de l'infection et que
quelqu'un aurait pas informé tout le
monde au bon moment je veux dire c'est
on dépasse les bornes là j'ai entendu à
londres avait calculé que la chine
devait payer 3720 milliers de milliards
et comme coupables de cette pandémie
tu certains vrais dit qu'il fallait
arrêter toutes les tous les biens tous
les actifs chinois à l'étranger pour que
la chine payait compassion g
j'ai les cheveux qui se dressent sur la
tête quand je l'entends parler des
choses comme ça certains proclame
officiellement à haute voix de telles
choses je trouve ça inadmissible et il
faut pas juger à sa propre zone
il faut d'abord sur ce qu'on a vu chez
certains dirigeants occidentaux
cherchent un collègue occidentaux tout
récemment par exemple il y avait le
porte-avions theodore roosevelt avec 550
marin touché du camp de vue c'était à
mon avis hein car peut-être même un
tiers des effectifs
et il ya eu la même chose aussi sur
d'autres porte avions ces américains
avec des épidémies de coronavirus il ya
dans la presse américaine des
commentaires sur des cas de caunes a vu
ce temps des bases américaines partout
dans le monde et c'est à peu près 800
sites certains qui sont autour de du
territoire de la russie de la chine
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et s'il
nous semble essentiel dans cette
situation ne pas désigner du doigt
quelqu'un mais comprendre que c'est un
malheur qui nous touche tous et que nous
pouvons le résoudre en travaillant deux
concerts en unissant nos efforts sans
criminaliser un pays ou un autre j'ai
une question sur les conditions de
travail
le département d'état américain a dit
récemment que parmi les diplomates
américains il ya à plus de 300 stations
secte et et il ya même quatre cas de
décès et qu'elle a les situations au
sein du mr russe nous avons
dès que le
l'état-major opérationnel a pris cette
décision nous avons pris des mesures de
précaution au sein du ministère et dans
nos institutions dans nos établissements
et de l'appareil central de du ministère
donc la moitié du personnel travaille
maintenant à distance c'est que le
personnel qui pour des raisons
techniques doit être dans les bâtiments
reste à sa place à son poste de travail
mais nous respectons la distanciation
sociales de toutes les règles de
précaution sanitaires sont appliquées
comme partout elle de voile
doivent-elles être en ce qui concerne
les établissements les déplacements
professionnels tous ceux qui travaillent
dans les consulats généraux les
ambassades suivent aussi toutes les
règles sanitaires ce qui suppose que il
ya des éléments de quarantaine notamment
dans nos écoles qui sont rattachés aux
ambassades ou consulats
donc je les l'enseignement à distance
s'étaient mises en place je dirais pas
que ça marcherait parfaitement partout
il ya eu des problèmes mais ce sont des
mesures qui sont prises tous les
tout le personnel qui travaille soit en
direct soit à distance fait l'objet de
tests réguliers dieu aie pitié de nous
et je dirais que si nous respectons
toutes les mesures qui sont édictées par
l' agence de des consommateurs de russie
tout devrait bien se passer la parole à
peut-être vous pouvez nous téléphoner
christina téléphonez-nous non ça ne
marche pas gentil mais pourquoi pas
peut-être elle peut téléphoner
christina christine a essayé de nous
rejoindre l'a apparemment nastia saurina
die die presse
à vous la parole bonjour monsieur la mob
je voudrais poser une question sur la
lumière parce que à 75 ans après la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale dans les
conditions d'une nouvelle montre mondial
nous avons essayé d'éviter une nouvelle
guerre mais malheureusement nous avons
maintenant cette guerre c'est une guerre
pour la vie dans le monde entier
la pandémie va toucher à sa forme et le
monde sera changé maintenant un chaque
pile août un tout seul bien sûr il y à
de l'aide de livraison italie et serbie
nous avons par exemple reçu de l'aide de
la part de la chine mais il n'y a pas
d'unité il n'y a pas de lutte vraiment
mondiale les pays et les unions ont
montré qu il
qu'elle ne fonctionne pas comment ça
peut influencer sur l'ordre mondial
merci à répondre à une des premières
questions j'ai rappelé le fait que le
troisième grand défi qui se pose
aujourd'hui dans cette lutte contre la
pandémie et les problèmes économiques
graves qui se pose aujourd'hui dans la
plupart des pays et au niveau
international
donc ce troisième défi c'est l'avenir de
ces grandes structures internationales
leur raison d'être leur capacité
d'existence dans et après cette pandémie
nous verrons quelles sont des structures
qui sont capables de survivre à cette
menace terrible à cette épreuve
je comprends que je comprends vos
craintes
c'est à dire que les manifestations
égoïsme de la part de certains pays que
nous voyons aujourd'hui elles peuvent
prendre le dessus et par la suite il
peut y avoir des tentatives de se
refermer de se séparer des autres
on voit aujourd'hui schengen qui se pose
la question de savoir comment vivre les
uns à côté des autres mais je pense que
il y aura quand même une approche
collective qui va triompher peut-être
pas tout de suite il faudra se
rencontrer discuter chercher à se
convaincre les uns les autres mais il
n'y a pas d'autre solution
nous devons aujourd'hui tous espérer
faire en sorte que cette crise soit une
sorte de vaccination contre l'égoïsme de
faire preuve de messianisme et continuer
à résoudre les problèmes
aux dépens d'autres pays aujourd'hui on
doit travailler ensemble il ya des faits
qui deviennent de plus en plus évident à
savoir que c'est de plus en plus de
diffuser de plus en plus difficile de
lutter seul contre de tels défis
d'ailleurs la rencontre à haut niveau
entre les cinq pays du conseil de
sécurité que nous avions points proposés
évidemment cette rencontre devra
examiner l'avenir de ces relations et 2
et sous format et le fonctionnement le
fonctionnement des institutions
internationales
maintenant la dernière question
christina vous avez réussi à nous
rejoindre
oui je vous entends mais cela frôle
malheureusement j'ai des problèmes
techniques
vous avez déjà parlé des livraisons de
l'aide humanitaire
quelles sont les réactions et est ce que
cela peut aider à lever les sanctions
s'était humanitaire oui on a parlé
plusieurs fois des sanctions et nous
avons dit que c'est un sujet qui nous
parlera entre était encore mais c'est
que si l'union coupe européenne comprend
que ce sujet a cessé d'être d'actualité
et que les décisions qui ont été prises
en 2014
à son volant nous serons prêts à
répondre par la réciproque mais nous
n'allons pas prendre l'initiative de
nous mêmes nous l'avons déjà dit
plusieurs fois dans cette situation où
nos partenaires nous ont trahis ont
renoncé à remplir leurs obligations
aujourd'hui nous devons nous appuyer sur
nos propres forces
dans tout
face à tous les revirements d'humeur de
nos partenaires ce ne signifie pas un
isolement de notre part au contraire
nous sommes toujours prêts à discuter à
coopérer mais après 2014
les pays occidentaux nous ont forcés à
nous
à être prudents vis-à-vis de leur
attitude et je rappelle encore une fois
que en ce qui concerne les événements de
2014 en ukraine c'est nous qui devrions
nous vexé contre l'occident qui en la
personne de la france de l'allemagne et
de la bonne et aussi des états unis qui
ont poussé ce lobby qui ont poussé donc
cette discussion entre le président
ianoukovitch et l'opposition ils ont
signé et juste le lendemain matin ont
piétiné l'accord qui avait été conclu
donc ils ont dit voilà la démocratie a
triomphé ce qu'est cette démocratie ce
qu'elle représentait on voit aujourd'hui
on a vu c'est la division en ukraine
c'est les organisations fascistes etc
j'en ai souvent parlé donc nous sommes
dans le sens contre les sanctions qui
ont qui sont prises sans l'aval de l'onu
mais nos relations avec l'union
européenne elles dépendront nous allons
rester patient nous allons agir de façon
constructive de notre côté et ensuite
qui concerne l'évolution des relations
avec ces pays
d'ailleurs certains pays pour beaucoup
sont d'union européenne
donc j'espère que les leçons de cette
crise seront tirées ces questions merci
à vous merci chers collègues que nous
avons organisé cette réunion en ligne
merci merci à vous merci merci
oui